CEO vaynermedia he's got a youtube show
pretty five bestsellers
Fortune magazine 40 under 40 he's
amazing he's in studio his name is Gary
[Applause]
thank you what did you put your money
into back in the day that people were
like what are you doing enough so back
in 2007 I put most of almost all my
money into Facebook and Twitter and my
financial advisors and all the old
liquor store guys I knew people were
just ridiculing me well they thought
everything was a fad right like my whole
career everything I've done people have
been telling me is a fad when I launched
an e-commerce wine site in 1996 the
internet was a fad when I started
running Google Ads instead of newspaper
and Direct Mail Google was a fad when I
started my youtube show YouTube wasn't
bad when I invested in Facebook and
Twitter that was a fad like everything
that I do
tends to be a fad or isn't gonna happen
usually when most conservative or people
above or older or successful than me say
something I'm doing is a fad I've come
to learn that's when I need the triple
down there's a couple things I want to
play for you right now
number one were you aware that there is
a Filipino star called Gary Vee very
much Carl can you come up he's huge I
said in the studio the other day I said
oh my gosh oh my gosh
so Gary Valley Chen who comes up I know
I saw his face when I first started
having internet kind of notoriety a lot
of people I mean he would always show up
it would always be brought up I think
I've done a good job in the last five
years
yeah well I've closed I've closed the
gap I'm close the gap I have a lot of
respect for it I've listened to too much
of his song
we've got him on the phone right now I
was hoping there's something else that I
want to do with my boo talking about our
kids you you're a family man yes just
real quickly again I want that advice
juggling the family and the business and
the life how hot is that how do you make
it easier is there a way I think it's
actually stunningly easy as long as you
don't succumb to other people's opinions
on how you should parent your children
or the current state of what's
politically correct it gets very easy
parenting comes very easy to me
I have great intent but you know for
example there's a big Thanksgiving kind
of recital in the morning for my kids
this week I'm gonna miss it cuz I'm here
I'm not happy about it but I'm not
crushed I'm not gonna judge myself like
I'm the worst dad of all time showing
your kids how to live happy is the
number one thing you can do for your
children but but you know you know but
my dad worked every minute because we
were immigrants he never came to
anything I did and very honestly my mom
didn't go to school stuff either she was
kind of like an immigrant lady issues to
herself like it you know basically for
me it's very binary do your parents love
you and put you in a position to be
happy everything else is checking the
box for everybody else talking about my
kids what I do this is what I've got
right now for you I've got my girls
Moshe and Kiki doing some of yours
Kiki my daughters she's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
so good these are your words what's
amazing and that's a big you know after
doing this for about seven or eight
years were you're getting a thousand
comments back an email DM whatever it
may be it took me a long time but I'm
like oh my god it's judgement it's other
people's opinions it was so foreign to
me because I was in such a cocoon
I never listened you know so many things
that kept me away from bad things as a
teenager was I was in my own head nobody
else's opinion penetrated me which
didn't lead me to those actions so it
was foreign to me to realize oh my god
the rest of the world lives a different
way yeah and and that is why I'm trying
to suffocate that because the more I can
get people into a place of feeling
confident about themselves for
themselves
it's unbelievable what happens when you
can actually cut out the noise of
judgment of others it's a big deal and
honestly and it's fun to be in this
region because it's it's a phenomenon
outside the u.s. even though it's big in
the u.s. its parents the amount of
people right now who are listening who
are living their lives 100% based on
their parents opinions is staggering now
let me create some clarity if you want
your parents to pay for your lifestyle
well guess what then they own you but if
you don't and you know and you want to
be happy and you don't want to be an
engineer or a doctor or an entrepreneur
or whatever it may be you first have to
get off the payroll be a big boy and
girl and then you have to do you may
have some short-term pain where your
parents are disappointed but long-term
you will have a far healthier
relationship because the only thing your
parents usually are worried about
unfortunately is the judgment of others
it's your it's your aunt that is the
hidden issue cuz your mom your mom's
trying to make you a lawyer because she
wants her sister to think you're
successful it's a very complicated
mindset but it's the truth
talking to you when the marks are off is
even more interesting yeah he doesn't
stop no you get people come in you get
you get artists and superstars they'll
come in and they turn it on when the
mics on interesting and when the mines
off they're off interesting and you you
you're on you're just you know something
you know and honestly I have empathy for
people that need to shut it off for me
this is like the most fun like people
like this is you know social media the
timing of my life is laughable to me to
me I love people so much interacting
with people is my oxygen asking about us
as people you know you were asking about
how we started not many people do that
when they come into the studio it's a
human connection since money connection
social media so if alpha which you're on
and this is what for us as radio
presenters it's the first time in our
careers that we're allowed we can
interact one-on-one with people that
listen to the show so I'll get it oh I
will get on to Instagram and Rapada
nearly every single Instagram message
that I get we couldn't do that you know
ten years ago that was this is a new
even though radio is an old-school
platform it's now a new school for us a
hundred percent and it's really the
origin of my career when I was doing the
wine show in YouTube there wasn't that
many people watching but every single
person that mentioned me or wine even on
Twitter I engaged with and I used to do
it for like nine ten hours a day and
it's really how I built myself up for
everybody who's listening who's trying
to become an influencer you know it's
not just taking a nice picture from the
frame right it's also engaging with the
three people that say that's an the
audacity of somebody who wants to become
famous and they get five comments and
they'd all have time to say thank you
yeah like you're you're not going
anywhere
I love that reply to their comments in
studio to three people listeners of this
show we put it out last week to ask Gary
a question I love this over a thousand
entries and I'm gonna bring in Jeremy so
nice to meet you how are you hey brother
how are you I met this guy outside of
Krispy Kreme and everything
how are you good on you guys
congratulations on being here I'm so
glad that a you listen to the show thank
you so much I'm gonna bring Jeremy up
first Jeremy if you can come up to the
microphone over here this is uh this is
what a lot of people want this
one-on-one time with Gary Vee right this
is this is a moment for you all right
this is so yesterday I was listening to
his podcast in the car thinking I wonder
if I met him what would I ask him yeah
24 hours later sat in front of him or
stood in front of it right quick
question yes we are actually launching
an online travel agency today Wow after
a year and a half of work we're
launching today so the timing is
unbelievable what's the name of it it's
Kudo to man which means everything's
cool in Arabic could you spell it for me
kul you okay you see am am calm okay
cool
it's a good start to the company great
so as as part of the launch we're trying
to build the brand around an event and
we've signed with Emirates holidays to
be a official travel agent for the Asian
Football Cup in January amazing we're
gonna run a competition to win trips to
the event and how do we boost that
engagement with the contest with a very
very small budget to me it's all about
Instagram diem right it's about DMing
people on Instagram letting now not just
trying to get them to build awareness
for you asking them hey this is what
we're doing what can I do for you this
is what's important to me and just look
at literally day by day we were just
talking about it day by day in the
trenches a hundred a thousand people a
day I mean in the beginning when you're
hungry to launch something it should be
hand-to-hand combat but I think
influencers are absolutely the
underpriced media of today's world and
especially in this market when I look at
it and so just the Eman 5,000 and I know
that sounds daunting but you know it's
just what you have to do in the
beginning 5,000 different people saying
we need awareness for this what do you
need and then bartering yeah
period loss is it live now if I go to is
like hey you lu t am am calm correct
congratulations Jeremy
very much Virtua Fighter with Gary
shortly my man I'm gonna bring call up
next Carl good morning here you are
we re where you from Carl from the
Philippines nice so nice what do you
wanna say Gary I've been watching all
your videos even before Instagram thank
you I know you lay out all the recipes
of success it's about the grind it's
about the hustle so on everything but my
question is you know it's about the
mindset but it sounds the question may
sound so cliche but how do you get
motivated despite all the factors that
comes into your life for me it's about
doing what you like I really I really
believe in that you know it's funny I
get asked about that question how do you
get motivated and for me it's very
simple it's it's what I like to do I
don't even feel like it's a thing of
motivation it's what I would do if I was
getting paid nothing so for me if you
love your process then you win it's kind
of like going to the gym it doesn't come
natural to me for other people it does
right and and they love going to the gym
and so they don't think it's hard and I
think it's hard I hire somebody to
travel with me to get me into the gym so
for me can you put yourself in a
position to do something that you like
then you'll be motivated most people are
chasing something they think has money
in it cryptocurrency influencer startups
entrepreneurship banking back in the day
whatever it might be they chase the
money and then thus it's hard to get
motivated because all they care about is
the money or the success not the nine
two nine seven two seven nine to five of
every day so for me interacting with
people talking about business running a
business is what I love to do it's why I
got D's and F's as a child in school
because all I want to do is sell stuff
and be a businessman so now I just do
that too many people think the thing
they love the most music art cooking
doesn't have any money in it because
they don't understand how the world
actually works playing video games used
to not have money in it now it has a
tremendous amount of money in it so I
would tell you to try to put yourself in
a position to like what you're doing
then you won't even think about
motivation Emma please welcome to the
marker
Gary Vee we're here so I I've been my
only business in Dubai for six years it
started up just something smaller to
work around the kids and it is I see the
potential in it it's got potential but
the social market changes so much yes
everything's changing fast and it's hard
to keep up with it so I guess my
question what what was working for you
when you say the social okay and now
know why organic or ads I don't
understand them it changes when you run
ads it's about not only who you're
targeting but you have the biggest issue
right now is people aren't making enough
content so you had an ad working that's
not working you need to make new ads
lots of new ads 50 videos 50 picture you
see where I'm going
Facebook works better than ever if
Instagram ads work better than ever the
problem is most people have one picture
or one ad or two that work then they
keep running it it stops working and
they think Facebook doesn't work anymore
without realizing it's the ad that's not
working anymore
do you understand it's as simple as that
and I'm gonna have some more time with
enjoying and Instagram influencers like
the first answer like especially in this
market Gary Vee you spent nearly an hour
with us really appreciate your time
thank you so much for joining us in
studio this morning ladies and gentlemen
you